uh and i want to bring in now former
speaker of the house newt gingrich who's
watching
all of this unfold tonight and again
newt everybody
on edge uh given what we remember from
just
may 31st last year after the george
floyd uh
death and not too far really seven or
seven miles or so from
the pictures we're looking at tonight
newt your reaction to these pictures
well i mean sooner or later we're going
to have to decide that we're not going
to tolerate
this kind of basically everybody talks
about the insurrection
on january 6th we've seen wave after
wave
of local insurrections where people
explicitly
reject the police attack the police in
many ways we have a war on cops
that nobody wants to really talk about
and we have a totally one-sided system
right now
sooner or later the society will demand
that we reestablish order that we
reestablish
safety and that we not tolerate people
who think they have the right to go out
and break the law and deliberately try
to undermine
what are the what in the end of the
forces of order uh you know i think that
a hundred police killed this year
i don't think a single one of them led
to a riot
not one uh but you have the system
across the country
from from seattle to portland to now
back to minneapolis
uh of people prepared on the on any
excuse
to go out and basically break down the
law well this is a marxist uprising is
it not
newt i mean this is this is a classic
chaos
disinformation propaganda vilification
this we've seen this play out over
history across
history and this is just one more
example that has
nothing to do with compassion for the
family of dante wright
it has everything to do with tearing
down a system they think is
in is systemically racist unjust
as a capitalist free market system they
want that gone
and if they can use the death of a of a
black man to do it they're going to do
it
and look the fact is in almost every
case we're talking about
it is poor african americans poor
latinos
people who are poor whites for that
matter people who are in neighborhoods
where they get preyed upon by criminals
so breaking down the forces of order
actually increases the danger to the
poorest americans
in a disproportionately a racial way we
had one democratic congresswoman
yesterday
call for the end of policing the end of
incarceration
now i want you to think about the level
of madness that this suggests
we already have a dramatic increase in
murder rates across the country
we're having a greater increase in in
theft we just had
walgreens announce that they were
closing every one
of their 10 drug stores in san francisco
because they can't cope with the scale
of theft
that is now permitted in san francisco
so you're watching the decay
of the entire civilization as the forces
that hate it
use every possible excuse and we let
them get away with it you have
you have video cameras nowadays you have
an ability to film every single person
who's there tonight go out and pick them
up arrest them
in some cases put them in jail in other
cases just charge them a very steep fine
make it too expensive to go out and
attack the police
you just saw in new york by the way a
totally un
unprovoked attack on a police car by a
group of thugs
who wanted to actually beat up the
police if they could have gotten into
the car
well newt we've had escalating attacks
against police officers across the
country
we've had ambushes of police officers
young especially african-american males
being told
over and over again that they're hated
by police
even african-american uh police officers
are having to deal with people who come
an
inch away from their face scream spit
every expletive
in their face uh who would want to be a
police officer
in an environment and especially a blue
state
where you let criminals run
wild with intermittent arrests and then
they're just released and they're back
on the street the next day
well well as you pointed out we've seen
this before
in the 1970s as the forces of law
collapsed
uh it led to a whole series of movies
like the clint eastwood series with
dirty harry
in which basically vigilantism came back
into being
because people just wouldn't tolerate
the level of fear
of the level of threat uh that was
happening around them
and this is what people need to
understand if the police collapse as a
system
you're going to have a genuine fight
between people who are protecting their
property
people who are protecting their lives
and those who are the forces of violence
of criminality and who want to dominate
by force
this is a very dangerous period we've
been here at least three times
since world war ii in the 70s where it
ultimately culminated
uh in massive problems again i think you
have it going on right now there's no
reason this has to be happening
and there's no excuse for it to happen
we need the rule of law
if a policeman does something wrong it
ought to be investigated
they ought to be tried and this is the
great irony about tonight
in minneapolis or in minnesota you have
a trial underway
of a policeman who has been accused of
killing a person so the system is
working
at this very moment you now have a whole
new cycle
where people say i'll go out on the
streets and as you point out
it rapidly deteriorates and begins to be
trashed
the local store which is very often
minority owned
it begins to be burned things down
and we do not have to tolerate this as a
society
but we have to have the courage to stand
up and say this is wrong
and people who engage in it are either
going to go to jail
or face very very severe fines yeah i
don't think these mayors and these uh
in these blue states have any
credibility they look like they've been
way soft on this
they're empathizing with criminals and
instantly thinking the worst of most
police officers
and so the police officers they're not
going to lose their their livelihood
lose their pension for at some point
they're going to decide
for what newt i'm going to put my stick
my neck out there
when i could be sued for everything i
have in some cases there's qualified
immunity but
they could they could lose their into
everything they work for
uh and then they're thought of in the
worst possible light
as criminals are coddled that's what
it's just i can't even believe what i'm
saying i love minneapolis i love
minnesota it's a wonderful state this is
just disgusting tonight it's disgusting
they're making an announcement right now
apparently newt uh
what is the announcement do you want me
to step out of the chat yeah they're
gonna start arresting people